[Música]
son las 8 y 29 de la noche en Bogotá
quito y Lima continuamos en directo
América edición nocturna Les agradecemos
su sintonía y vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
en Perú el expresidente Pedro Castillo
negó rotundamente que sea autor o haga
parte de una organización criminal
formada durante su gobierno esto justo
cuando se cumplen tres meses de su
destitución y detención hoy mismo la
presidenta dinamó el lugar te declaró
ante la fiscalía por la mortal represión
a las multitudinarias protestas de los
últimos meses tenemos análisis
el portavoz del departamento de estado
de Estados Unidos Indicó que no
descartan declarar terroristas a los
carteles del narcotráfico en México esto
tras El secuestro en la ciudad
fronteriza de Matamoros de cuatro
ciudadanos estadounidenses dos de ellos
fueron asesinados
Francia vivió la que Hasta ahora ha sido
la jornada más masiva de movilizaciones
en contra de la Reforma pensional más de
un millón de personas siendo las calles
de decenas de ciudades para condenar la
ley que retrasa la edad de jubilación y
aumenta los años de trabajo necesarios
para recibir la pensión completa Tenemos
reporte desde París
[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzamos en Perú donde se cumplieron
tres meses de la destitución y detención
del expresidente Pedro Castillo un
turbulento periodo marcado por las
multitudinarias protestas reprimidas
violentamente por las autoridades según
la defensoría del pueblo 60 personas han
perdido la vida en las movilizaciones
justamente por ello Este martes la
presidenta Dina boluarte declaró ante la
fiscalía para analizar esta información
conectamos con Paula tábara Pineda
politóloga y profesora de posgrado en la
pontificia Universidad Católica del Perú
bienvenida a France 24 qué balance se
puede hacer de este periodo de boluarte
en el poder
creo que lo que marca este periodo es En
definitiva la fuerte represión de la
movilización social y la falta de
escucha tanto por parte del gobierno
como por parte del parlamento que está
respaldando el gobierno en el pedido de
buena parte de la población las
encuestas nos hablan de hasta 80% del
pedido del que haya un adelanto de
elecciones lo antes posible bueno hay
una amplia condena al gobierno de la
mandataria Cómo se ve su panorama y que
viene para el ejecutivo
hay efectivamente en el en el panorama
inmediato un incremento de las
movilizaciones que se detuvieron durante
el mes de febrero en varias regiones
producto de las festividades que suelen
darse pero que ya están anunciadas en la
ciudad de hecho desde la región de puno
de la población la población aymara se
está movilizando hacia la capital y eso
va a recrudecer la mandataria va a tener
que demostrar que realmente está
dispuesta a escuchar o si va a seguir
optando por la represión como hemos
visto y como hemos visto incluso este
fin de semana nuevamente con lo cual
parece difícil que lleguemos a algún
nivel de paz o tranquilidad sino que nos
mantendremos en un conflicto social
fuerte bueno ya hablemos de Pedro
Castillo cómo va su proceso
su proceso está aún en la primera parte
declaraciones este fin de semana además
se contaron algunos videos se hicieron
públicos videos en los cuales se ve como
él dirigió efectivamente la operación
del mensaje a la nación por el cual
intentaba dar un autogolpe No él había
tratado de indicar que esto había sido
un poco forzado y las imágenes
demostraron que no era así que junto con
su primer ministra y su asesor y ex
Primer Ministro habían decidido este de
golpe con lo cual es muy improbable que
él pueda salir y más bien en los
próximos días deberían definirse los 36
meses de prisión preventiva que se están
pidiendo para él pues los casos de
corrupción y por el tema del autogolpe
también Paula Pues a usted muchas
gracias por su análisis por compartirlo
con nosotros en France 24
vamos a México el gobernador del estado
de Tamaulipas Indicó que su país y
Estados Unidos llevan a cabo una
investigación binacional sobre el caso
de los cuatro estadounidenses que fueron
secuestrados y dos de ellos asesinados
por integrantes de carteles en la ciudad
fronteriza de Matamoros según las
autoridades el asesinato se produjo tras
confundir la identidad de los
estadounidenses desde Washington
Cristóbal Vázquez corresponsal de France
24 nos entregó más detalles en el
siguiente reporte
de las cuatro Víctimas de secuestro de
los ciudadanos estadounidenses en México
dos de ellas están muertas una persona
está herida y la otra está viva sí lo
dijo directamente el gobernador de
Tamaulipas Américo Villarreal hablando
por teléfono en conferencia de prensa
diaria con el presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador los cuatro
estadounidenses ingresaron inicialmente
a la ciudad fronteriza de Matamoros en
México desde brunchville Texas en una
Minivan blanca con placas de Carolina
del Norte Cuando hombres armados
empezaron a disparar contra su vehículo
así lo dijo el FBI luego los hombres
armados subieron a los estadounidenses a
otro vehículo y se los llevaron las
autoridades mexicanas consideran varias
teorías sobre el ataque entre ellas de
que los estadounidenses fueran
confundidos con traficantes de
inmigrantes haitianos sin embargo
estadounidenses viajaron desde Carolina
del Sur a México para acompañar a un
amigo hacerse la abdominoplastia ya que
la cirugías estéticas son mucho más
económicas en México
cero de el Consejo de Seguridad Nacional
de Estados Unidos dijo a periodistas
desde la casa blanca que Estados Unidos
estaba trabajando ya con las autoridades
mexicanas para obtener mucha más
información sobre este secuestro en
Matamoros y que las cuatro víctimas
regresarán a Estados Unidos muy pronto
el partido opositor venezolano voluntad
popular anunció que Juan guaidó será
candidato en las elecciones primarias de
Cara a los comicios presidenciales de
2024 Juan guaidó hasta el pasado mes de
enero era la cara más visible de la
oposición y autoproclamado líder del
gobierno interino desde el año 2019
voluntad popular se opuso a la
disolución de dicho gobierno ahora en
las primarias intenta consagrar una
nueva unidad opositora
como una jornada histórica así
calificaron algunos sindicatos franceses
la sexta y más reciente jornada de
manifestaciones en rechazo a la
propuesta de reforma al sistema de
pensiones que lidera el presidente
Emmanuel macón las protestas tuvieron
lugar en una gran cantidad de ciudades
del país y provocaron demora su
suspensiones de varios servicios desde
la capital francesa Natalia Ruiz nos dio
más detalles de la jornada de protestas
para los sindicatos el objetivo de este
día era un martes en negro un día en que
todo el país fuera bloqueado con huelgas
y manifestaciones Puede que no haya
habido un bloqueo completo del país pero
lo cierto Es que Francia sí estuvo a
media marcha a lo largo de todo este día
con huelgas generalizadas en el sector
de la educación de los transportes
especialmente el transporte público en
ciudades Como por ejemplo aquí en París
así como en el transporte ferroviario
que de hecho el tráfico de los trenes
esta perturbado hasta este próximo
jueves también huelgas en las refinerías
la mayoría de las refinerías del país
que suspendieron todas sus actividades a
lo largo de este día ahora lo cierto Es
que aquí en París al menos 700,000
personas salieron a manifestar esos casi
el doble en realidad de lo que sucedió
hace 15 días en la última manifestación
y en todo el país también fue una mayor
participación falta saberes Entonces
cuál va a ser el efecto de todas estas
manifestaciones en la posición del
gobierno Lo cierto es que entre los
manifestantes encontramos algunos que
todavía creen que hay esperanza de que
el gobierno retire este proyecto de ley
de reforma pensional de pasar la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años Aunque hay
algunos que creen que ya no hay manera
de dar marcha atrás pero todavía pueden
hacerse algunas mejorías En todo caso al
texto de ley y mientras la gente está
manifestando en todo el país al mismo
tiempo el senado continúa el examen de
la proyecto de ley y se espera ya para
el 15 de marzo que haya una comisión
paritaria siete diputados siete
senadores que deben reunirse para ya dar
una versión final de este texto que
luego volverá a ser votado por ambas
cámaras para finales de este mes
entre tanto en Ucrania avanza la batalla
por la ciudad de bahamut en la región de
donnietzka según kiev antes de la guerra
vivían 70.000 personas en la urbe pero
tras meses de destrucción solo quedan
4000 civiles los combates continúan y el
presidente
declaró que sus tropas seguirán
defendiéndose de la sedios ruso por otro
lado el ministro de defensa de Rusia
sergeygu aseguró que ganar esta batalla
es crucial para avanzar en la ofensiva
en otro plano del conflicto de este
martes kiev y Moscú intercambiaron
prisioneros de guerra Rusia confirmó la
llegada de 90 combatientes mientras que
Ucrania recibió 130 militares de sus
filas 87 de los cuales habían sido
capturados en mariopol según informó la
presidencia ucraniana
en el marco de otra sesión de la
asamblea popular nacional en Beijing
Este martes el ministro de relaciones
exteriores chino King Gang ofreció una
conferencia de prensa para manifestar
los intereses chinos en la escena
internacional abordaron temas como las
relaciones entre China y Rusia el
conflicto en Ucrania la cuestión de
Taiwán y las recientes tensiones con
Estados Unidos el informe es de Max
Pérez Gallardo
un llamado chino a detener la contención
el ministro de exteriores chino expuso
la actualidad de la política exterior
del país y las tensiones con Estados
Unidos fueron El plato fuerte
chingan fue enfático en expresar la
negativa china a entrar en confrontación
con la nación americana y llamó a la
cooperación Aunque el funcionario
advirtió que si Estados Unidos no deja
de presionar a China el futuro de la
humanidad podría estar en riesgo
si Estados Unidos no pisa el freno y
continúa a toda velocidad por el camino
equivocado no se podrá evitar el
conflicto y el enfrentamiento Quién
soportará las catastróficas
consecuencias esta competencia es una
apuesta temeraria en la que está en
juego los intereses de ambos pueblos e
incluso el futuro de la humanidad china
se opone firmemente a esto
la guerra en Ucrania también fue uno de
los temas abordados por el ministro las
recientes acusaciones del gobierno
estadounidense sobre una supuesta
asistencia militar del gigante asiático
a Rusia provocan indignación en Beijing
chungo
China no ha creado la crisis ni es parte
de ella no ha proporcionado armas a
ninguno de los bandos del conflicto
porque se culpa se sanciona se presiona
e incluso se amenaza a China es
absolutamente inaceptable
China y Estados Unidos tienen un
historial de altibajos en sus relaciones
que hoy se encuentran en un momento
complejo debido a posiciones encontradas
con respecto a temas como Taiwán la
guerra en Ucrania y la polémica derivada
del denominado cloe espía un escenario
en el que algunos ven sombras de la
Guerra Fría
en el marco del día internacional por
los derechos de la mujer que se
conmemora este 8 de marzo la empresa
Barbie anunció el lanzamiento de una
muñeca afrodescendiente asemejanza de la
científicas facial Maggie adrien pococh
los detalles en el informe de Alba
Santana
todo el mundo quiere celebrar el 8 de
marzo del día internacional de los
derechos de las mujeres hasta las
grandes empresas como Barbie pero este
año desde la multinacional de muñecas
han querido ir un poco más allá y
reivindicar otra minoría estigmatizada
las mujeres afro sacando a la venta a
una muñeca de la científica espacial
Maggie Adri poco
algunas personas se sorprenden de que
una mujer negra sea científica espacial
me gusta romper esos estereotipos
siempre que tengo la oportunidad
la puesta de Barbie no es casual adherir
un poco es expresidente de la asociación
científica británica muy conocida por su
trabajo con el telescopio James webb y
por presentar el programa de Sky at
Night de la bbc y quiere animar a más
niñas a tener carreras como la suya una
de mis misiones en la vida es tratar de
animar a las niñas en materias como
ciencia tecnología ingeniería y
matemáticas son demasiado importantes
para dejarlas en manos de los chicos su
muñeca lleva un azul estrellado que
evoca el cielo nocturno un telescopio
para ver las estrellas e incluso sus
características mechas Y es que la
científica quiere hacer que las niñas
afro se sientan identificadas cuando era
niña las Barbies no se parecían en nada
a mí así que tener esta que soy yo
literalmente fue muy emocionante esta
doctora tiene muy clara sumisión en la
vida animar a las niñas a perseguir sus
sueños hasta alcanzar a las estrellas
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a que continúen con
nosotros que ya llega Andrés espinal con
toda la información de nuestra red de
corresponsales en el mundo feliz noche
para todos
[Música]